[Música]
el presidente de Francia Emmanuel macón
se reunió con el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden su encuentro marca el
regreso de las visitas de alto nivel
diplomático a la ciudad de Washington en
la era postpandemia ambos países tienen
la necesidad de mostrarse Unidos de
mostrarse como países cercanos ante
adversarios que tienen en común Como por
ejemplo Rusia debido a la guerra en
Ucrania y china en materia comercial y
espacial el encuentro ha servido también
para reconectar a estos dos países que
han sido aliados históricos pero que
habían sido testigos de un enfriamiento
de sus relaciones porque hay varios
temas en los que discrepan por ejemplo
las medidas adoptadas por Washington
para reducir la inflación considerada
por la Unión Europea como una medida
proteccionista sobre este tema se
pronunció justamente el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden escuchemos no
había ningún propósito cuando escribí
esta pieza legislativa nunca pretendía
excluir a personas que estuvieran
cooperando con nosotros la intención la
intención era asegurarnos de que ya no
estuviéramos en una posición donde
ocurriera una pandemia en Asia de China
decidiera que ya no quería vendernos
chips de computadores nosotros
inventamos eso Entonces
mi punto es que estamos de vuelta los
negocios Europa también y vamos a
continuar creando trabajadores en
manufactura en Estados Unidos pero no a
expensas de Europa ahora como
corresponde veamos La otra cara de la
moneda la respuesta francesa estas
fueron las palabras del presidente
Emmanuel Mako pero yo sé que esta no es
la intención del presidente biden pude
hablarlo ayer con distintos senadores y
representantes en el congreso y Me
confirmaron que esta no era su atención
Francia no vino aquí a pedir cualquier
excepción o excepción para su economía
sino que vinimos a hablar de las
consecuencias de esta ley y
la situación actual nos obliga a actuar
conjuntamente frente a los desafíos
mundiales tenemos que
sincronizar nuevamente encontrar una
dinámica positiva nueva porque tenemos
que trabajar juntos bueno eso digamos
que es lo más relevante en materia
diplomática y en materia comercial pero
esta visita tiene mucho más tras la
escena que estamos viendo ahí de los dos
presidentes En una conferencia de prensa
el mensaje que envía la comunidad
internacional y esa cercanía entre París
y Washington es un mensaje poderoso para
la comunidad internacional porque su
cercanía repercute en escenarios muy
importantes Como por ejemplo la otan lo
que pacte París y Washington puede tener
una repercusión en esta Alianza militar
del Atlántico Norte en lo que vaya a
suceder en Ucrania también a nivel
comercial y sobre todo a nivel de medio
ambiente y puede también tener un gran
impacto a nivel internacional si ellos
logran coordinarse y engranar en esencia
el futuro de la en Ucrania la relación
comercial y la dependencia con china en
materia comercial el liderazgo a nivel
internacional y el desarrollo
tecnológico y espacial fueron tal vez
los temas más fuertes de este encuentro
pero vamos a analizar en profundidad
aquí en France 24 todos estos temas
conversados por estos dos presidentes
por eso hoy en el debate de France 24
tras los pasos de Manuel macron por su
gira en Estados Unidos en Estados Unidos
para analizar este tema hemos invitado
America él es analista internacional es
docente de relaciones internacionales de
la pontificia universidad javeriana en
la ciudad de Bogotá me acompaña aquí en
el estudio de France 24 y desde la
Ciudad de México se conecta la doctora
aribel Contreras ella es coordinadora de
la licenciatura en negocios globales de
la universidad iberoamericana ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte del debate ya lo saben pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el debate F 24
arrobas antílogo que es mi cuenta
personal ni la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo pegado todo junto no se olviden
también ya para terminar que todos los
contenidos del programa ya están
disponibles también en diferentes
plataformas de podcast nos encuentran en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn hay muchas personas que nos están
oyendo a través de estas plataformas de
podcast a todos ellos también les damos
un saludo y Les agradecemos por su
sintonía
pues comienzo como corresponde por las
mujeres aymeric ya le doy la palabra
para conocer El Punto de partida la
primera pregunta de inicio del programa
y saludo entonces a la doctora aribel en
la Ciudad de México
en Doctora aribel gracias por estar con
nosotros como siempre Un gusto conversar
con usted y cuál es el balance que usted
hace de esta reunión entre los dos
presidentes de Francia y de Estados
Unidos
al contrario de Santiago un gusto poder
estar aquí contigo y con todo tu
auditorio importante Resaltar que esta
Cómo llegan ambos mandatarios a esta
reunión por un lado sabemos que Manuel
marcó está en el segundo periodo después
de haber ganado una reelección al
interior de su país donde también hay
una gran polarización política y social
como lo existe ahora en Estados Unidos
Cómo llega Joe biden pues no con las
pérdidas que se habían estimado a la luz
de los resultados de las elecciones
intermedias en en la Unión Americana
entonces ambos mandatarios pues llegan
con un escenario de que llegan
fortalecidos con nuevos retos eh Por los
próximos cinco años para Manuel Mac pero
para los próximos dos años de Joe biden
pues complicado por la nueva composición
al interior de del senado donde ya
perdió la mayoría a partir de enero
próximo estamos viendo que esta reunión
que que se da a la luz de estos dos
líderes países miembros del g7 Es decir
de este grupo las siete naciones más
industrializadas que finalmente han
avanzado y cobijado Ucrania la luz de
esta guerra
por Rusia entonces importante que se
diera esta Cumbre porque también
Santiago había Todavía este ligero o
profundo malestar por parte del gobierno
francés por esta crisis que se desató en
septiembre del año pasado por la alianza
geopolítica
cibernética y de geopolítica cuántica
mejor conocida como el aucus entre
Australia Reino Unido y Estados Unidos
donde Francia quedó fuera y se violentó
un acuerdo que existía entre Australia y
Francia entonces Creo yo que inclusive
esta reunión pudiera decirse que llegó
hasta inclusive hasta tarde Creo yo que
tenían que haberse reunido ya desde hace
meses atrás pero bueno que que la
realizaron porque pudieron
alinear sus visiones intercambiar
opiniones que totalmente estaban en
caminos Opuestos sobre todo en el ámbito
económico y que sin duda cerraron filas
para poder hacer frente a los nuevos
retos y desafíos que por separado cada
país se enfrenta pero que de manera
conjunta les queda muy claro que tienen
que avanzar para seguir construyendo
esta relación fuerte donde se le
acuestan multilateralismo y donde se le
apuesta a muchos foros multilaterales
que coinciden ambas naciones Santiago es
muy diciente que sea el presidente
macron el primer presidente que llega a
Washington durante la administración del
presidente biden y también es muy
diciente que sea Estados Unidos el
primer destino del presidente macón
después de su reelección ahora saludamos
a nuestro invitado en el estudio
bienvenido como siempre Un gusto tenerlo
aquí en el en el programa y cuál es su
balance de este encuentro los temas
analizados a nivel nos hacía un poco el
contexto político de los dos países pero
que hay de los temas y de la agenda
analizada y tratada por los dos
mandatarios Buenas noches Santiago lo
que vemos es que el contexto es muy
diferente a comparación con la primera
visita de estado que hizo Macro en 2018
en Estados Unidos en esta época Trump
estaba en el poder en esta época se
hablaba mucho del tema de Irán del
acuerdo nuclear y Trump decidió salir
Oficialmente de este acuerdo nuclear
justo después de Esta visita se hablaba
mucho del tema del terrorismo de la
situación en Siria y hoy vemos que el
tema principal tema central es por
supuesto el tema de Ucrania pero no
solamente la guerra entre Ucrania y
Rusia sino todas las consecuencias de
esta guerra sobre la economía sobre la
crisis energética sobre el tema de la
inflación Y entonces
Ucrania ha sido por supuesto el tema
central además de la dimensión simbólica
sobre la cual tal vez volveremos a
hablar de este encuentro después de una
crisis que hubo hace un año entre
Estados Unidos y Francia Claro que sí
tras el acuerdo que mencionaba aribel
ese acuerdo que compromete Australia al
Reino Unido y Estados Unidos lo vamos a
profundizar más adelante
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa y me preguntaba en dirección
hacia qué tan necesario era para la
coyuntura internacional no solamente
para la realidad de Estados Unidos y de
Francia una renovación del espíritu y de
la relación histórica entre Estados
Unidos y Washington qué tanto se
necesitan los dos países Bueno creo que
como se ya se ha dicho son dos estados
miembros del g7 son dos estados miembros
del Consejo de Seguridad son dos
potencias nucleares Y entonces son dos
estados importantes en las en las
organizaciones internacionales
miembros de la otan Y entonces ahí la
voluntad de demostrar una unidad en este
contexto de Thompson con Rusia una
visión compartida de estos dos estados
frente a esta crisis creo que eso es el
punto central y es por eso que en la
conferencia de prensa se ha insistido en
esta juración sólida en la historia hace
siempre que hay un encuentro entre
Francia y Estados Unidos se recuerda el
apoyo de Francia para la independencia
de Estados Unidos la acción conjunta en
las dos guerras mundiales y Entonces
hubo una voluntad por lo menos en a
nivel mediático de demostrar esta unidad
Aunque sabemos si lo han lo hemos visto
al principio con el reportaje sabemos
que hay esta tonsión y este problema
sobre la ley de lucha en contra de la
inflación en Estados Unidos que provoca
críticas por parte de Macro de macron y
también de la Unión Europea valga la
pena decirlo de la palabra ahora a nivel
en Ciudad de México a nivel la
importancia de este reencuentro y
también el mensaje que se envía a la
comunidad internacional en particular a
China y a Moscú a Rusia
totalmente Santiago porque por un lado
vemos que uno de los principales
temas de esta reunión tiene que ver
con proveeduría de energéticos es decir
Estados Unidos ya desplazó a Qatar te ha
desplazado Australia ahora como un
principal proveedor
del gas natural obvio haciendo un lado
el 40% que hace meses atrás Rusia
metía a la Unión Europea entonces
Estados Unidos está ganando En ese
sentido ante la coyuntura pero se tenía
que abordar el tema de los energéticos
porque sabemos que a la luz de las
medidas de la OPEP Pues fue una jugada
la inversa lo que yo va a Irene esperaba
los precios internacionales han subido y
por lo tanto Estados Unidos le vende muy
caro el gas natural licuado a toda
Europa algo que hoy Emmanuel bajó puso
muy sobre la mesa muy claromente de la
importancia que era verse al interior de
la economía doméstica de Estados Unidos
se pudieran realizar ajustes para que
ellos desde Europa no tenga que
comprarla tan cara el segundo punto sin
duda tiene que ver con compartida de
política de seguridad con respecto a la
región indopacífica es decir es decir
ahí ya subió al barco como decimos acá
en México a Francia para que ya no se
quede fuera de esta jugada de cómo puede
abonar Francia a esta estrategia para
hacerle frente justamente a China en la
región de
la región intopacífica pero también
abordó en su conferencia cuando dice que
le va a gustar mucho poder estar
presente en esta cumbre de los países
africanos porque sabemos que es un
continente donde quien más tiene
presencia es china a través de su
diplomacia de la deuda otro punto
importante que me parece que hay que
destacar es cuando yo habla sobre las
cadenas de suministro transatlánticas no
es decir como Estados Unidos y Francia
pueden sumarse para avanzar en cadenas
de suministro y que de esa manera los
europeos no queden fuera de esta
estrategia de la ley de inflación y
donde se le está apostando a que al
interior de Estados Unidos de
preferencia se consuman autos eléctricos
fabricados en Norteamérica entonces Creo
yo que esa es una manera de darle vuelta
a la jugada de estas molestias que
inclusive Emmanuel el presidente bajó
había dicho ya previo en otro discurso
al interior de Washington frente a la
comunidad francesa donde él ponía sobre
la mesa que sí estaba bastante molesto
porque esta ley de Estados Unidos estaba
mermando la relación comercial Entonces
yo creo que de manera digamos rápida
Esta es como el abanico de los temas
principales donde se le está apostando y
donde seguramente estarán encaminando
nuevas estrategias para que el comercio
bilateral aumente y que esto a la vez no
merme estas ligeras tensiones que
existían en el pasado Santiago pasó a
preguntarle a
adentrándonos en el tema comercial
Estados Unidos habitualmente defiende
sus intereses como lo ha demostrado a lo
largo de los años cuando tiene que tomar
algún tipo de decisión para favorecer su
crecimiento económico o su estabilidad
política aquí se han mostrado muy
abiertos como lo estaba poniendo en
contexto a nivel en hacer Alianza y lo
decía yo en la introducción si esto
engrana puede traer una gran repercusión
a nivel internacional en términos de
comercio a los dos lados del Atlántico
Pero qué tanto se puede confiar en
Estados Unidos en un gobierno como el de
biden que ya solamente le restan dos
años y que probablemente uno de los
escenarios que pueda llegar es un giro
de la página y que vuelva a llegar un
personaje Como por ejemplo Donald Trump
que claramente puso agua de por medio en
su relación con Europa Sí de hecho la el
comportamiento de los Estados Unidos con
Byron no es tan diferente a la actitud
de Trump y es decir que
va y dónde defiende los intereses de los
estadounidenses toma mucho en cuenta la
objeción interior toma mucho en cuenta
la opinión pública la presión del
Congreso Y entonces los intereses de los
Estados Unidos son los intereses de los
Estados Unidos y pues hay podemos
recordar también una frase del General
dugur que ha tenido una relación
compleja con los Estados Unidos que
desean los estados no tienen amigos
solamente tienen intereses Y entonces la
lo que vemos es que del lado europeo hay
una queja de decir que los Estados
Unidos no toman en cuenta los daños de
la guerra en Rusia porque la Unión
Europea tenía mucho más interdependencia
con Rusia que los Estados Unidos
entonces la Unión Europea sufre mucho
más de las consecuencias de esta guerra
entonces hay una voluntad de tener una
política más concertada con los Estados
Unidos la voluntad también de tomar en
cuenta entonces para a los europeos la
actitud de los Estados Unidos y el
mensaje de Finalmente es más para los
europeos que para vaidón makón sabe que
Byron no va a cambiar esta ley esta ley
es considerado como un éxito paraba a
nivel interior y lo que busca Mako es
tener del lado europeo una respuesta
frente a la actitud de Estados Unidos de
decir a los europeos debemos defender
nuestros intereses y debemos Nosotros
también adoptar medidas a favor de
nuestras empresas a favor de nuestra
industria y es un mensaje en particular
para Alemania donde hay ciertas
reticencias frente a la adopción de
políticas un poco más proteccionistas si
en Alemania mucha expectativa en torno a
esta reunión a nivel también se muestra
al presidente macoco como muy líder de
la Unión Europea dejando un poco de lado
a Alemania que está tomando una posición
menos política y más preocupado por el
tema por el tema económico a nivel
internacional digamoslo Así ha evitado
meterse tanto en temas políticos pero
cito una frase que dijo en su momento La
cancillera alemana Ángela Merkel Y decía
Estados Unidos ya no es el Aliado de
confianza que teníamos antes esta
reunión de hoy este acercamiento con
París Porque en buena parte también
Macro no está representando a la Unión
Europea en cierta forma está tomando ahí
un liderazgo de la Unión Europea es ese
Aliado de confianza otra vez o es
simplemente un acercamiento necesario
a propósito de Ángela Merkel sin duda
extrañamos esa gran alianza que siempre
hacía majó con ella iban de la mano y
entonces Creo yo que esa Alianza logró
fortalecer mucho el Binomio Francia
Alemania y que por cierto hago un
paréntesis que no olvidemos de la visita
que hizo Ángela Merkel a Washington
durante el año 2021 dicho lo anterior
estamos viendo al menos desde mi
perspectiva
a un canciller o la shorts más
minimizado es decir no tiene este
carácter ni este liderazgo que se
requiere el interior de Europa y sobre
todo ahora en tiempos de guerra este
liderazgo ahora ha sido muy bien pues
abordado Y aprovechar esta coyuntura
Porque estos huecos los ahora retomado
sin duda Manuel Mako Y porque también
ante la pulverización de lo
políticamente se ha vivido en Reino
Unido Pues tampoco vemos a un actual
Primer Ministro que lo haga entonces
ahorita yo creo que Europa y
específicamente la Unión Europea le está
apostando a al presidente
galo Para que avancen estas alianzas
pero que sin duda Sí se sí se muestra y
y yo creo que lo vemos muy claramente
Santiago Todavía este este ligero sigilo
de desconfianza porque finalmente
Estados Unidos va por lo suyo o sea
Estados Unidos
al activarse economía de guerra pues va
por sus intereses geopolíticos y Geo
económicos y no precisamente es el un
socio de confiar y mira que lo digo yo
como mexicana que ahorita traemos ahí
varios temas con Estados Unidos el tema
en cuestiones comerciales entonces
podemos decir sin duda que lo el mensaje
que mandan hoy al exterior en cuanto a
este frente común les está saliendo muy
bien pero eso no significa que a no haya
grandes diferencias en diferentes
ámbitos y que lo sabe muy bien marcó que
los próximos dos años pueden ser de una
manera pero que en dos años no
precisamente tendrá un gran Aliado en la
casa blanca porque aunque Donald no sea
el candidato de los republicanos sino
que sea el actual gobernador de Florida
John de santis
puede ser que ahí haya cambios de
ajustes Así que desde mi perspectiva es
Santiago Lo que se planea es a largo
plazo trazar las rutas para una relación
bilateral más fuerte marcaré una ruta
para una relación por lo menos más
cordial ambos lados del Atlántico hay un
punto importante que tiene que ver con
la otan lo mencionaba también al inicio
del programa lo que ellos pacten aquí
tienen grandes repercusiones a nivel
internacional entre ellas en la otan el
presidente biden se ha mostrado abierto
a esa propuesta del presidente Majo de
crear un sistema de defensa propio de la
Unión Europea algo que también genera
muchas controversias dentro el bloque de
los 27 pero recibir por lo menos este
apoyo o buena mirada o beneplácito por
parte de Washington siempre hay un buen
camino para despegar en ese en ese
proyecto esto es viable América crear
este sistema de defensa de la Unión
Europea y le alargo un poco más la
pregunta aquí entonces cómo puede
reaccionar Rusia otro país Como por
ejemplo Turquía Se podrían sentir
amenazados
muy antiguo Francia justamente había
salido del mundo integrado de la otan en
la época del General de Google para
defender una mayor autonomía en materia
de defensa y para criticar el poder de
los Estados Unidos sobre Europa y eso
durante la época de la Guerra Fría el
presidente sarco es en 2009 decidió
volver en el mundo integrado de la otan
él dijo que de esta manera se iba a
facilitar la fortaleza pues la
construcción de una ropa de la defensa
no hemos visto Muchos avances en la
realidad desde esta época porque hay
reticencias por parte de Estados Unidos
pero sobre todo porque hay resistencias
por parte de los estados europeos de
muchos estados europeos de Alemania que
tiene y que ha tenido un presencia
militar importante de los Estados Unidos
durante la Guerra Fría y que todavía
tiene presencia militar estadounidense y
hay sobre todo una alineación en materia
de defensa de todos los estados de
Europa del este que habían sido bajo
regímenes comunistas y que decidieron
adherir en la otan y alinearse con los
Estados Unidos después de del fin de la
Guerra Fría Entonces es muy difícil para
broncear gonzar sobre este asunto y más
aún en el contexto actual porque
finalmente la guerra reforzar la unión
de la otan reforzar la importancia de la
otan hubo un reforzamiento de la
presencia de tropas de la otan en el
este de Europa e incluso Francia y macul
que había criticado la otan en ciertos
momentos en particular en 2019 él había
hablado de la muerte cerebral de la otan
en esta época pero fue más en crítica
con la acción de Turquía en este en esta
época incluso Francia pues hoy en día no
critica la otan y dice que hay la
voluntad de construir algo a nivel
europeo Pero complementario entonces
estamos en debates que ya existen desde
mucho tiempo pero que no dan
perspectivas reales de autonomía fuerte
Europea aribel Cuál es su opinión Porque
da la coyuntura esto también nos diría
que esa necesidad de reforzar un sistema
europeo de defensa es también porque
están viendo que el conflicto en Ucrania
puede alargarse mucho más de lo que
estaba calculando tanto
Moscú como el resto de la comunidad
internacional
por supuesto Santiago y parece que se le
está apostando a no enfrentarse a
ciertos vetos como ya lo mostró Turquía
frente a la otan entonces Creo yo que al
menos ellos en términos regionales sin
duda le tienen que apostar a avanzar en
sistemas de seguridad europea a la luz
de esta gran amenaza internacional que
representa Rusia en términos militares
pero también representa una amenaza
internacional china en términos
comerciales Como así ellos decidieron
plantearlo no lo digo yo ellos lo lo
pusieron así en la pasada cumbre de lo
tan realizada en la ciudad de Madrid
durante el mes de junio entonces vemos
Que Europa tiene muchas amenazas ahorita
podemos hablar únicamente del tema de
Rusia Pero veo nuevas amenazas que tiene
que ver desde las amenazas de las
cadenas de suministro lo que representan
este surgimiento de los avances
tecnológicos las cadenas de suministro
cómo están desfragmentadas alrededor del
mundo y que entonces Europa lo que menos
quiere es volver a vivir otra crisis de
de lo que se lo que se vivió justo en la
época de la pandemia como fue el El Gran
caos con las vacunas no se acordarán
este tema de que las farmacéuticas no
podían exportar vacunas porque era su
territorio etcétera y a la Luz sin duda
también pues del brexit tiene que darse
un planteamiento de que a pesar de las
diferencias entre la Unión Europea y
Reino Unido en términos comerciales y
todo lo que está pendiente con respecto
a Irlanda Creo yo que al menos en la
gran coincidencia que que hay Es que hoy
más que nunca se le tiene que apostar a
tener blindada su seguridad europea
porque las amenazas continuarán no solo
por la guerra en Ucrania Santiago sino
porque me parece que más adelante pueden
existir otro tipo de amenazas de otros
actores internacionales otro punto
importante de este encuentro es esa
declaración del presidente biden que ha
dicho que está preparado para sentarse a
conversar con el presidente de Rusia
Vladimir Putin para hablar de cualquier
tema por supuesto el primero sería el
tema de Ucrania hay que recordar que el
presidente Mako ha sido uno de los pocos
líderes de Europa y del mundo occidental
digámoslo Así que ha tenido comunicación
directa con el presidente Putin desde
que comenzó la invasión al territorio de
Ucrania sabrá uno si Putin si le presta
o no atención al presidente macron como
sí lo hacía por ejemplo con La
cancillera alemana Angela Merkel a quien
sí parece le prestaba mucha atención a
sus comentarios pero por lo menos es una
puerta que tiene occidente para
comunicarse directamente con el kremlin
esto era un mensaje directo más que
directo desde Washington a Moscú
haciendo un bypass por París como lo lee
usted América Sí yo creo que hay muchos
debates Incluso en Estados Unidos dentro
del ejército dentro del congreso hay
divisiones sobre lo que se debe hacer al
principio había realmente la voluntad de
no discutir de apoyar totalmente a
Ucrania todavía y la voluntad de apoyar
a Ucrania Pero hay también muchos
debates y muchas reflexiones para saber
cómo se podrá resolver Y acabar esta
guerra hay también todo el riesgo Pues
de nuclear entonces para los Estados
Unidos es importante que hayan canales
de comunicación hay canales de
comunicación directos entre Estados
Unidos y Rusia pero no a nivel de los
mandatarios Es decir para bailones mejor
para su imagen interna no tener
discusiones por el momento hasta el
momento directas con Putin para Macro es
diferente porque en Francia hay la
visión de considerar muchas veces que
Francia debe ser un actor que permite el
diálogo incluso entre enemigos que
permite con la diplomacia resolver
ciertas cier
Y eso provocó en ciertos momentos
dijo que no se debe humillar a Rusia
pero en el mismo tiempo ma consiste
diciendo que él siempre que habla con
Putin cuenta después hacer el contenido
de la discusión y presenta también pues
la posición común de
los estados miembros de la otan
Maribel su opinión
Creo yo que hoy en día esta reunión sin
duda nos queda muy claro y al
descubierto todavía hay temas pendientes
eso
o sea lo veo yo y no sabemos qué es lo
que vaya a pasar con respecto a una
posible negociación de paz lo que sí
queda claro es lo que hace semanas atrás
yobaiden había dicho que había hablado
con Selena de que pensar y reconsiderar
la posibilidad de sí sentarse a negociar
con Vladimir Putin algo que se le esquí
por supuesto dio un rotundo no y después
sacó su pliego es su decálogo de de
peticiones durante el g-20 sin embargo
veo que yo baiden si le está apostando a
que antes de que concluya su mandato
esta guerra tiene que concluir porque si
no entonces el altísimo costo el costo
político que le va a heredar a su
partido en las elecciones del 2024 pues
pudiera ser prácticamente entregar la
Casa Blanca Entonces si hay alguien que
por un lado le conviene la guerra por la
economía de la guerra en Estados Unidos
esa Joe biden vaya la valga la dicotomía
pero al mismo tiempo a él también le
interesa que esta guerra tampoco se
prolongue demasiado en términos de costo
político electoral Entonces estamos
viendo que está intentando yo va a ir
jugar muy bien sus fichas para ver en
qué momento pudiera enviar a un emisario
nuevamente para conversar con Putin si
es Emmanuel no lo sabemos si puede ser
alguien más también lo desconocemos pero
sin duda Europa
quien tiene un liderazgo pues ese Manuel
marcó y yo creo que más adelante
estaremos viendo una nueva visita en
Moscú entre estos dos mandatarios donde
le hará saber y le hará llegar el
mensaje desde Washington el mensaje
emitido por el presidente biden vamos
llegando al bloque final del programa
Tengo que hablar del tema espacial por
supuesto Esos grandes convenios que
pueden existir entre Estados Unidos y
Francia en materia espacial ambos países
con muchísimos intereses en esta
renovada carrera por conquistar el
espacio por conquistar la luna por
conquistar otro planeta Y esto es
simplemente para hacerle contrapeso al
avance que ha tenido china justamente en
días atrás china
le contó al mundo entero que había
puesto en órbita algunos taconautas y
que ya está próxima a poner en
funcionamiento una estación espacial
allí para hacer una avanzada también
como un Punto de partida para llegar a
la luna esto pues preocupa por supuesto
a Estados Unidos preocupa por supuesto a
Francia también Rusia tiene ahí su su
preocupación en cuanto estaba avances
Chino aquí que tanto pueden cooperar
porque tanta necesidad de esta carrera
espacial macron lo dijo bueno el espacio
es como el nuevo escenario de de
confrontación pero pero qué tanta
necesidad hay por estar allí
Bueno creo que es un tema de prestigio
no de Rango es decir fonciano tiene la
posibilidad la capacidad de emprender
probablemente un proyecto de manera
pues unilateral Entonces es la necesidad
de cooperar sobre este punto ha sido
desde hace un año un tema justamente de
Reconciliación después de la crisis de
locus con la constelación de la venta de
los submarinos a Australia fue un tema
de discusión cuando la vicepresidenta
estadounidense vino a Francia y en este
viaje efectivamente hubo la presencia de
dos astronautas y la voluntad de
discutir sobre este gran proyecto
artemis de volver a la luna y para
Francia sería pues tal vez la idea de
tener un astronauta un primer europeo en
esta misión
y a nivel porque hay tanto miedo ante el
avance chino en materia espacial Y la
verdad es que lo han hecho muy bien y lo
han logrado en tiempos récord El Avance
que ha tenido china en esta materia
sin duda alguna Santiago estamos viendo
que se repite aquella carrera espacial
que vivíamos durante la Guerra Fría hoy
nuevamente sin embargo los actores han
cambiado en el sentido de que ya no es
la unión soviética sino ahora el gran
país hegemónico que va a la delantera
pareciera Pues que es China y de ahí que
están viendo occidente que solos no
pueden es mejor ir juntos ir de la mano
parte del mensaje de Manuel McQueen el
día de hoy donde en esta nueva carrera o
en este nuevo maratón pero era espacial
parece que entonces hay países que como
es Reino Unido como es Francia Estados
Unidos pero también se sumaría ahí
posiblemente Japón Corea del Sur donde
están haciendo un frente común porque me
parece que tanto lo que es el Ártico lo
que es el espacio y las aguas
internacionales se han convertido en el
nuevo campo de batalla y de intereses
geopolíticos y donde el gran enemigo de
occidente sin duda y lo dijeron muy
claro pues ha sido china Durante los
últimos años y este año pues se suma
Rusia Así que veo yo que además del tema
comercial y además del tema militar son
estos nuevos frentes en Santiago que se
abren en nuevas aristas y por lo tanto
la puesta es conquistar y llegar primero
a la meta antes que pudiera ser Lucía o
china el espacio además es un es un
frente de batalla en donde no hay leyes
el espacio no pertenece a nadie entonces
todo está permitido en esa carrera
espacial por parte de estos países hay
que Añadir un actor que también está
tomando muchísima fuerza y son los
emiratos árabes Unidos que han tenido
también un desarrollo rápido en materia
espacial con un proyecto que no se
mostraba muy ambicioso pero va haciendo
y cosechando algunos éxitos ya me quedan
par de minutos para cerrar el programa
quiero dejarlos entonces para que
ustedes hagan las conclusiones de lo que
deja Esta visita lo que puede repercutir
en las próximas semanas macron todavía
sigue de Estados Unidos le falta todavía
visitar el estado de Luisiana un estado
que tiene
historia común con un pasado francés
y por eso va a estar así por eso va a
estar allí el presidente haciendo
presencia dejo entonces aymeric para que
haga su conclusión lo destacable de esta
de este encuentro Bueno creo que es un
encuentro importante una visita de
estado con todo un protocolo con un
encuentro entre dos mandatarios by Danny
pero es una visita que va más allá de
esto porque hay también muchos ministros
que vinieron ahí encuentros entre
ministros ahí también o empresarios
entonces hay que ver la dimensión global
de Esta visita y todas las temáticas
como el espacial como el tema de la
defensa como el tema comercial etcétera
Y entonces hay muchos aspectos muy
técnicos específicos además de la
dimensión simbólica de la oración
bilateral entre Estados Unidos y Francia
para Francia creo que el desafío es por
supuesto de conservar un estatuto de
potencia a nivel internacional de seguir
siendo un interlocutor de Estados Unidos
sin ser totalmente alineado con los
Estados Unidos y es el lema tradicional
un poco de la política exterior de
Francia Aliado sin ser alineado Y eso es
más difícil en los últimos años por la
consecuencia del retorno en el mundo
integrado de la otan por la tonchón
actual y por las dificultades en el
funcionamiento de la Unión Europea con
las divisiones internas importante ese
punto de aliados pero no alineados
Francia tiene sus propios intereses
También bien marcados y los hace y lo
deja muy claro siempre a través de estos
encuentros dejo para el cierre entonces
a nivel su conclusión
importante sin duda Resaltar Santiago
que esta reunión que es una reunión
claro histórica y que cada parte
defiende sus intereses Creo yo que les
faltó todavía
nos quedaron a deber poder avanzar y
poder cubrir aquellos intereses
compartidos es decir eh Estados Unidos
también tiene que cuidar los intereses
de Francia en otras regiones y viceversa
a qué me refiero a que no nada más se
trata de ver los intereses bilaterales
sino también inclusive ver cómo se
pueden incluir estas regiones como es el
hecho de todas estas ex colonias
francesas en diferentes partes algunas
son zona natural de influencia de
Estados Unidos y de igual manera la
importancia que Francia tiene en América
Latina que la zona natural de influencia
la tiene Estados Unidos a esos a lo que
me refiero que nos quedaron un poco a
deber pero sin duda Creo yo que el
resultado es positivo el saldo Es
favorable para dos naciones y ahora Pues
habrá que ver los resultados concretos
Santiago a nivel como siempre Un gusto
conversar con usted aymeric un gusto
como siempre tenerlo aquí en el estudio
de France 24 les agradezco por este
análisis para la audiencia
nuestra cadena en América Latina es todo
por el día de hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos su sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Pedro Ruiz y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Lina Guzmán
Gracias por estar con nosotros siga con
France 24
[Música]